Problem that if you don't address is not
going to get any better and it probably
is going to get worse.
People don't address the problems
in society until it affects them.
What do you think they could do though?
Like how, besides just education,
how do you stop as much crime?
How do you give people like counseling?
Like you can get the guns out of Chicago.
You can get the guns out of anyway
if you want to. You think so?
How would they get them done? They
would get most of the guns out, right?
You can get, you can get most of
the guns out, you can do that,
but do you run the risk of taking guns
away from people that could defend
themselves in a really dangerous area
that's filled with guns by taking,
by taking the guns out.
Like what about people that are also set?
Like who are you going to
take the guns away from?
You got to take the guns away
from the lady who runs the bakery,
who carries a lot of cash at the end
of the day. Lady that runs the bakery,
keeps her gun lady that
runs the bakery that has a,
that has a business that provides goods
and services for the neighborhood that
wants to protect you.
That once protection keeps her gun.
Did you see that recent video?
There's a crazy video of these two
gals behind the stove and one lady was
cooking yesterday and got punched her in.
The Guy Comes back in Wales,
her in the head and then the other girl
pulls a gun. She keeps our gun. Yeah,
that she keeps her gun because shit
like that might happen. But that got,
now imagine if he had a gun. That's a
good thing for people to see. This is why.
And I'm not saying
everybody should have guns.
It's a good thing for people
to see because we, oh, you
only hear the other side.
You only hear guns being
dangerous and killing people.
You don't hear people like that lady
that just saved herself from getting the
fuck beat out of her with a gun. I
know, I saw, I saw that video. Uh,
and then I saw the other video was
a a guy and a jewelry store. Yeah.
It comes in three, two or three
guys. Hoodies on, mask on.
You see the guy who's coming through
the door pulling their man's down. Ooh.
It's like on the camera.
And then you see a guy walk
away from the jewelry display.
He walks the camera's shooting this way.
So he walks out of range of the
camera and when the guys come in,
he comes back blasting.
Boom. Whoa. I keeps his gun.
Jesus. He just started shooting as soon
as they came in. Guns out. Oh Jesus. Yeah.
So what happens? It was like,
it was customers in there
too. So he know he hit one.
He did the first guy.
Yeah.
And other two ran out and you see
the guy run out of camera range.
Imagine being in a fucking jewelry store
trying to buy a watch for your wife and
a gunfight breaks easement ring.
You just like, I'm so in love.
Me and my girl are going to get,
and the guy just comes in and
you think this could be it.
This is how I'm going to
go. My kids, you know what?
This is a sign we shouldn't get married.
Ah Ah sorry.
I just have too much PTSD to get married.
That's what the task. That is hilarious.
Yeah, but she can we run a business.
You keep your, keep your gun. Yeah.
I'm just the guy on the corner.
20 guys on the corner. Cops stopped
him frisked. Okay. Taking these guns,
it's going to be hard to get them all man.
And the problem is defining who gets to
keep one and who doesn't get to keep one.
It's very sketchy. Let's
have that argument later. Get
the guns first. Well does,
but the problem with that is you're
never going to get them back.
Like if once you take them away,
whoever got the guns taken away,
they're never getting their guns,
but know that you got to take
the guns and then you have to,
there has to be more to just that.
You've got to take the guns and it has
to be an increased police presence.
You have to take the guns have to be
something to do with school. Lets out,
you have to take the guns and
they have to be a, you know,
counseling for drug offenders and you
take the guns and it has to be jobs in the
neighborhood. You know, it's a lot of
steps that have to cope, but you can,
it can be done. Um, you can
definitely get the illegal guns,
right? If you could somehow or another
get access to them, the illegal guns,
the legal ones are going to be real tough
because if someone has a gun legally
and they haven't committed a crime,
it's going to be real hard
to take that gun away. Yeah.
But I don't think if they did the numbers,
the guys with legal guns aren't the guys
that are committing these crimes. Right.
The guy would leave your gun.
I'm pretty sure it isn't the guy that
drove past this party and she got up right
then you got to worry about the people
with legal guns getting robbed for their
guns. Right. If guns become a shortage,
the whole thing is very, it's a, it's
a real problem and it's very, um,
it's very complicated I think
to try to completely solve it.
And how do you get these people that
are in that life that are every day
involved in gang violence?
And I don't think I could be wrong.
I don't think everybody that's
in gang life wants to be there.
I think you're right. No,
I think definitely right.
I think they just like what the fuck
else is there to do in this neighborhood.
I right. You're right. I think if
they had an opportunity to, you know,
I think the guy, the kid that is
a very good basketball player,
that his uncle was, like I said,
his family lineage gang life.
If he had a chance to go
play basketball somewhere,
he would take that chance.
I think you're totally right.
And I think in the absence
of any other chances,
that's when it becomes
something that's an option.
And I think it's all about
the same feeling that people
get when they're joining
gangs or when they're, um, oh,
like a staunch right winger
or a staunch left winger.
I think it's all the same thing.
It's like people have a desire to
belong to something. Absolutely.
Make something that makes
your life have more mean.
I feel like it has more meaning.
Absolutely.